okay let's talk about something else the
Internet in Europe this week there were
some potentially significant news it is
said the internet never forgets until
now that is
any huge ruling the highest court in
Europe ruled that Google and other
search operators like it must delete
search results if they are requested
they're calling it the right to be
forgotten the right to be forgotten
which incidentally is definitely my
favorite non-existent Morrissey song I
have the right to be forgotten
[Applause]
yes what what the ruling amounts to is
that if there's something embarrassing
on the internet about you then EU
citizens can now ask Google to take down
any links to it all as CBS attempting to
explain it to their older viewers you're
looking at things that are actually
material to you that you may not be able
to find it's basically like saying in a
library you can have books that people
don't like the topics but you've got to
take the cards out of the card catalogue
Oh what is it possible to use a metaphor
more archaic than that one information
is like a penny farthing bicycle
the data is the spoon break ISPs are the
after wheel and users are the deerskin
covering on the saddle spring I'll tell
you who seems weirdly excited about this
potential new right the newscasters
reporting on it let's hypothetically say
when you were in high school you toilet
papered someone's house you were
arrested but that one night of wild
drinking in college can haunt you
forever online what if ten million
people suddenly approached Google and
say by the way you're not story about me
running over a squirrel on my bicycle
while drunken naked I want that removed
that is way too specific to be something
that we just came up with off the top of
his head I guarantee you that there is a
photo of that man naked on a bike
crushing a squirrel and if there isn't
then frankly there is now yes meat meat
for you top Google image hits Brian
Sullivan and live with this for the rest
of your life maybe mainly my favorite
newscaster fantasy stirred by this
ruling came this week from Fox News's
Shep Smith I'm trying to think what I
would give to just be forgotten chef I
might Rob all the banks on the planet
just because you raised yourself on the
internet doesn't mean you won't be
caught for robbing bats
that's not how basically anything works
but it's genuinely charming that you
think it is
I just like to rob banks that's all
that's kind of my thing maybe this new
ruling though addresses a genuine
problem the Internet has an unforgiving
memory and it can ruin people's life so
if all the ruling does is let people
take down links to minor indiscretions
from their past it's probably fine a
source that has knowledge of these
requests says that a man in Europe who
was convicted of child pornography was
among the first people to request two
links that links to articles about his
conviction that's probably taken down a
politician with some bad behavior in
office even a doctor with a negative
review okay a fail-safe question to ask
yourself when drafting a law is might
child pornographers like this if so
maybe take another pass at it luckily
the only thing stopping this ruling from
doing real damage is that it is by its
nature completely ineffective because
what the alien Court doesn't understand
is that the Internet is like quicksand
the more aggressively you fight to
remove yourself from it the deeper
you're going to sink down into it and
the case in point is the guy who started
all of this the case originated in Spain
a man there argued that when a Google
search turned up an auction notice of
his repossessed home from back in 1998
that somehow that being out there was a
violation of his privacy rights that
spanish man is mario costeja gonzalez
this is his photo which was on an
article from the New York Times about
his crusade to remove links mentioning
his debts from 1998 in doing so he is
now world-famous for being that Spanish
guy with debts from 1998
the only thing I know about him is the
only thing he didn't want me to know and
that that is why all of this all of this
is why the rights to be forgotten is no
longer workable in the Internet age
nothing you are embarrassed of on the
Internet is ever going away and we all
have a horrifying photo from our past
that undermines the very person we are
now professionally and personally and we
can all live in fear of that thing ever
surfacing or we can all hold hands jump
at the same time and save each other
which is why we are launching tonight
hashtag mutually-assured humiliation if
we all put our worst photo into the
world together none of us will ever be
in a position to judge anyone else ever
again and I am NOT talking about the
cute mildly embarrassing photo like I
don't know that one of yourself wearing
a let's say homemade sweater with your
own name on it hypothetically
hypothetically the kite the point that
you break that's real the point that you
claim is embarrassing but actually
somehow humanizes you a little no I'm
talking about this toxic
in fact yes I am putting this photo up
online right now we all have to do this
together
I am trusting you all to do the same
three two one
you have to do this whipping right go
you better of done that as well
or I've just made a horrible mistake and
I think I may have just made a horrible
mistake
[Music]